ce
merci beaucoup
bonsoir a tous frappés steve gadd est
mais lorsque j'ai commencé à faire du
rap
j'ai changé de nom et je me suis appelé
fola je suis originaire de la guadeloupe
mais je viens martinique depuis quatre
ans il est environ 20 ans j'ai rencontré
un mouvement qui allait bouleverser ma
vie et ce mouvement là c'est le
mouvement hip hop aujourd'hui je suis ce
qu'on appelle à mettre conférence
j'enseigne l'histoire des états unis à
l'université des antilles sur le campus
de schoelcher
mais avant d'arriver là j'étais un jeune
guadeloupéen fasciné par ce qu'il voyait
à la télé dans les magazines et en 1998
j'ai décidé de commencer à rapper et ce
mouvement là il a changé ma manière de
parler aux gens il a changé ma manière
de comprendre le monde
il a changé ma manière de réfléchir mais
pendant que je le mouvement hip hop
ap en même temps je faisais des études
je faisais étude sur le campus de
schoelcher en martinique et mes études
ses études d'anglais et j'ai étudié
l'histoire la littérature des pays
anglophones de l'afrique à l'europe aux
états unis dans la caraïbe en passant
par l'australie gp ces études là je suis
allé le plus loin que possible et à un
moment donné il m'a fallu faire de la
recherche
lorsque j'ai été en master et pour
pouvoir faire de la recherche
eh bien je n'ai pas chercher longtemps
pour trouver mon sujet et j'ai trouvé la
culture hip hop je les utilise et gelé
du moins analysé sur plusieurs angles je
les analyse et en tant que mouvement
noir aux états unis je les analyse et
dans le monde entier en tant que
mouvement multiculturelle je les analyse
et aussi dans sa relation avec la
caraïbe
comment elle s'était enraciné chez nous
pourquoi et qu'est-ce qu'elle avait eu
comme impact sur nos sociétés à nous
ensuite moment doctorants j'ai analysé
le
rapports entre le mouvement hip hop et
le mouvement rastafari
parce que j'ai vu qu'il y avait des
jeunes aux états unis dans la caraïbe
qui mélangeait ces deux mouvements ces
deux phénomènes culturels très puissant
et qui exprimer leur créativité
à partir de ces mouvements là ensuite
j'ai commencé à travailler à la fac
avant ça j'ai fait autre chose j'ai fait
de la peinture j'ai fait de l'intérim
parce qu'il fallait payer les factures
fallait payer le boire et le manger
j'ai fait autre chose et pendant un
moment aussi j'ai été au chômage je vous
avoue que le chômage ça a été une bonne
expérience dans le sens où aujourd'hui
quand je suis dans ma salle de cours
quand je j'échange avec mes étudiants
c'est une réalité qui ne me quitte
jamais je suis pas un prof qui est
complètement déconnecté de ce qui se
passe dans la société
non je sais ce qui nous attend nous
parfois les jeunes même très diplômés au
pays
et ça me serve lorsque je suis arrivée
en martinique
j'ai commencé à mener des expériences
particulières
qu'est ce que j'ai fait je suis un fin
connaisseur des cultures urbaines
je suis un pratiquant mais je suis aussi
un chercheur donc j'ai commencé à aller
dans les collèges et les lycées
pourquoi parce que j'ai vu l'impact que
les cultures urbaines avaient sur la
manière dont le jeune réfléchissent la
manière dont il se comporte la manière
dont il s'habille la manière dont ils
ont des relations hommes-femmes
alors je suis allé dans certains
collèges je suis allé dans un
établissement du l'horaire en passant
par fort de france
schoelcher j'ai bougé dans pas mal
d'établissements dans les collèges et
les lycées
j'ai rencontré des jeunes qui sont
désireux d'avoir des conversations
authentique des conversations pas avec
des gens qui du haut de leur chaire
viennent leur dire ouais mais c'est sa
faute et avoir faux pas on fait ça non
il était désireux d'avoir des échanges
authentique avec des gens qui les
respecter les gens qui reconnaissait
qu'ils avaient de la valeur et que leur
mode d'expression était tout aussi
important que n'importe quel autre mode
d'expression dans le pays
journalisme demande souvent mais est ce
qu'ils sont à l'écouté
je leur réponds que oui je réponds que
oui et je vais vous donner quelques
anecdotes
j'ai utilisé les clips vidéo les clips
vidéo on voit faire notre jeunesse
les collégiens les lycéens et parfois
ceux qui n'étaient pas à l'école dans
d'autres cadres
j'ai utilisé les clips vidéos pour les
faire réfléchir sur leur estime d'eux
mêmes la manière dont les jeunes hommes
se voient c'est à dire qu'est ce que
c'est pour eux la virilité un homme un
vrai c'est quoi la manière dont les
jeunes femmes se perçoivent leur
féminité pour elle c'est quoi une femme
qui est bien dans sa peau qui est
attirante qui est compétente c'est quoi
qu elle doit avoir qu'elles attribuent
j'ai utilisé les clips vidéo des
cultures urbaines pour pouvoir réfléchir
aussi sur le rapport à la réalité
c'est-à-dire les substances vous savez
que l'adolescence la jeunesse un temps
tourmentés sept ans aux commandes on est
en train de se chercher parfois les
substances sont une porte pour faire des
expériences je parle de tous types de
substances psychoactives
je parle aussi même de l'alcool
j'ai utilisé les clips vidéos pourront
initier des dialogues avec les plus
jeunes que je rencontrais il y à une
substance qui est un peu en vogue
malheureusement en guadeloupe et en
martinique
c'est ce qu'on appelle le sirop la
colline la codéine sais pas si rond
qu'on peut acheter en pharmacie et que
les plus jeunes
mélange à des limonades où il mélange à
deux boissons sucrées et en buvant sa le
sirop plus la boisson sucrée et bien
c'est une substance psychoactive et ça
leur donne un trip comme le ferait
n'importe quel autre substance mais moi
connaissant ce qui se passait aux états
unis
je sais ce qui se passe aussi en
jamaïque et dans d'autres pays je sais
que les artistes qu'on voit à la télé
avec les gobelets rouge où les gobelets
blanc
je sais que ça lui est rien arrivé
plusieurs fois d'avoir les problèmes de
santé je sais que certains sont décédés
sont morts dans leur chambre d'hôtel
je sais que certains aussi ils n'ont pas
eu de problème avec les substances parce
qu'ils avaient assez d'argent pour aller
dans des centres de réhabilitation vont
se faire nettoyer l'estomac se faire
remettre un peu en forme donc ils ont eu
sa une un peu moins cet impact sur eux
mais les plus jeunes dans notre pays ne
savent pas forcément toujours ça ils
suivent parfois des comportements qu'ils
voient et qu'ils aimeraient adopter
parce que ça leur permet d'être dans le
coup et le faire les expériences se
souvient je suis allé une fois dans un
lycée nord de la martinique et après que
j'ai discuté avec deux clips à la pluie
sur l'impact des substances et que ça
pouvait tuer notamment ceux ci rôle à la
colline que ça pouvait faire les
battements du coeur ralentit que ça
pouvait fait aussi les gens c'est tout
fait il y à un jeune lycéen et après
notre discussion est allé voir
l'infirmière de son établissement un peu
en panique et lui a dit il ne pensais
pas que ça pouvait aller aussi loin et
qui veut vraiment arrêtez arrêtez de
faire ça alors quand je réponds sur
l'impact que cela peut avoir
je crois que oui ça fait réfléchir ça
fait rentrer en soi mais il nous faut
toujours le faire je le fais ces
échanges là je le fais avec beaucoup de
l'offre
beaucoup d'amour beaucoup de
compréhension aussi parce que je
n'oublie pas qu'il y avait tant gte ya
vingt ans j'ai été commuée donc j'essaie
de me mettre à leur niveau comprend un
peu où on en est et je parle pas un
français châtié comme sale accrocheur et
que leur avons laissé nos mains
rabat les cons ou quoi comprendre
pourquoi pas aller avait parlé france en
public rigole en tranquille
rabouin cool au contraire pour installer
une bonne ambiance et il y a d'autres
fois où je suis allé dans les
établissements
j'ai poussé les garçons et les filles à
réfléchir sur la manière dont les filles
la manière dont on les voyait dans les
clips vidéo je leur ai expliqué parfois
que les femmes qu'on voyait dans des
clips vidéo c'était les personnes
étaient des employées et des employés
qui venait qui faisait un travail
particulier qui avait un chèque et
lorsqu'elle sortait du clip vidéo et
bien se rhabiller elle ne l était pas de
la même manière que qu'on les voyait
donc les imiter c'est parfois être à
côté de la vraie réalité les garçons je
les encourage souvent à ne pas voir les
jeunes femmes et les femmes seulement à
partir de leur corps ou à partir de leur
sex-appeal
j'essaie de réveiller leur sensibilité
leur dire qu'une femme une jeune femme
c'est avant tout une personne c'est
quelqu'un c'est pas un ou deux corps
c'est pas une relation sexuelle ou c'est
pas du sexe et pas simplement ce qu'elle
dégage c'est une personne entière qui a
ses particularités et qui mérite d'être
respecté d'être analysée d'être regardée
à partir de toutes ses composantes la et
s'égrènent là je crois vraiment qu elle
porte du fruit
il ya une autre expérience que j'ai
menée je vais une fois toutes les deux
semaines à la prison de ducos
j'ai à coeur particulier pour les
détenus et particulièrement les
accidentés de la vie parce que j'en ai
été un bien que en particulier pour eux
parce que je crois que
un séjour en prison ne devrait pas être
la fin d'une vie non on devrait pouvoir
continuer même si les accidents de
parcours
alors je fais deux choses quand je vais
à la prison de ducos à la prison de
ducos
je fais du rap noël ou d'autres périodes
on convoque les artistes qui le veulent
bien et on va à la prison de ducos et on
offre un pont c'est un spectacle où les
deux nus ça permet de faire baisser la
tension ça permet de s'évader un peu
parce que la prison c'est un lieu
anxiogène qui répondent à cette première
partie là mais un mercredi sur deux j'y
vais pour autre chose
et là j'y vais pour animer un atelier
d'écriture créative
je suis un rappeur chaîne m6 j'écris
depuis très longtemps je sais comment
amener les gens à l'écriture déclenché
cette envie de parler de soi parler de
choses qui nous intéresse et là je ne
vais pas encore des adultes
je vais au parti des mineurs au quartier
des mineurs
je passe deux heures avec mes plus
jeunes élèves est d'abord on discute de
l'actualité de leur vie de comment ils
sont ensuite on se met d'accord non
avant de se mettre d'accord
je lui en parle d'une personne qui a eu
l'occasion de faire un séjour en prison
mais dont la vie a été bouleversée par
la créativité qu'elle a eue en cuisant
par l'écriture en prison et j'arrive à
toujours trouver un personnage comme ça
j'arrive par exemple alors parlé de
shaka senghor qui aux états unis a été à
ma place dans un tedx et qui a
bouleversé beaucoup de gens l'écriture a
été sa rédemption prison je leur parle
de personnes comme omis abu-jamal comme
malcom x et bien d'autres comme chez
nous en guadeloupe
alain team allons qui a été un bandit
notoire mais par l'écriture qui a ouvert
une autre fenêtre sur sa vie après est
donc dans ces moments là c'est des
moments particuliers je vais pas vous
dire que ça se passe toujours bien que
j'arrive toujours à obtenir des
résultats
this faisant puisque c'est un lieu comme
je disais anxiogène parfois quand je
vais là-bas souvent la veille il ya eu
un problème il ya eu une agression et la
parentrie la combo qui double des
solidaires des profondes entre quand
j'en perds valentine azote et en contre
qui la met l'autre groupe la famille des
doigts au moyen de machines et engins
suivant à pas vous dire on va rentrer
fingers in the nose
non mon gp mais j'y vais parce que je
sais que j'y vais pour quelque chose de
particulier j'y vais pour une mission et
parfois j'ai des élèves qui ne sont pas
qu'ils ne viennent pas ou les points
j'en ai qui ont des attitudes qui ne
sont pas toujours coopératifs qui ne
coopèrent pas forcément mais quoi qu'il
en soit il se passe des choses
lumineuse je vous donne quelques
anecdotes au moins une ou deux il y un
jeune homme qui avait 14 ou 15 ans et
les sorties aujourd'hui lorsqu'on a
commencé une de nos sessions
je leur ai demandé de me parler de leur
quartier il s'est mis à écrire et n'a
pas arrêté de créer là écrit pendant
environ 40 à 45 minutes sans savoir que
le rapport à la page c'est très fort
pour eux c'est un exploit quand même de
s'inviter en un petit moment et de faire
que ça que l'écrire et l'a écrit comment
est ce qu'il est arrivé à la criminalité
qu'est-ce qui la fascine et pourquoi et
qu'est ce qui s'est passé et je le
regardais je l'observais écrire il était
dans un autre monde
il m'a dit après que le waouh ça lui a
fait quelque chose il n'avait jamais
écrit autant et quand j'ai lu ce qu'il
avait écrit cité bouleversant
l'écriture c'est un moment où on descend
au fond de soi il faut parfois beaucoup
de courage pour ça et la vie tous les
jours nous empêche de faire ça c'est un
moment on est face à soi et ce moment là
pour ses plus jeunes où ils sont dans le
silence face à eux mêmes ce sont des
moments très déclencheur ce jeu là il
est sorti il dérange un projet de
réinsertion dans pays en guadeloupe il y
a eu une autre expérience où cette fois
ci j'ai demandé
à mes élèves de réfléchir à leurs
victimes
si il avait quelque chose à dire à leurs
victimes à exprimer qu'est ce qu'ils
auraient dit certains d'entre eux m'ont
dit qu'ils n'en ont rien à faire et
qu'elle est au mauvais endroit au
mauvais moment
c'est son problème de savoir composer
avec ça je ne les ai pas à juger je n'en
ai demandé quand même d'essayer
s'ils veulent bien écrire et vous savez
une posture à avoir c'est un endroit qui
difficile où les relations entre
personnes ce sont des relations qui sont
basés sur le pouvoir physique
l'intimidation est donc il ne faut pas
être parmi les faibles se montrer
compatissant
c'est être parmi les gens qui sont soft
et est faible alors ils n'ont pas
forcément tous voulu écrire mais y en a
deux ou trois qui l'ont fait et en a un
qui ne l'a pas fait tout de suite
il l'a fait deux semaines après vous
savez quand je suis revenu il m'a dit
qu'il avait un texte à me montrer et m'a
montré son texte et son texte disait
voilà je ne pensais pas en fait je
pensais comme un victime rigoler je ne
pensais pas que ce que j'avais fait l'ue
avait fait autant de mal et j'ai compris
petit à petit en fait que oui
ce que je lui avais fait il avait fait
du mal et je vais pouvoir faire
autrement je raconte aussi un peu un jeu
les faits une injustice parce que c'est
parce qu'il a dit vraiment je raccourcis
un peu mais en tout cas j'étais face à
un jeune qui était descendu en lui-même
descendu pardon en lui-même et qui avait
réalisé qu'ils avaient touché du doigt
quelque chose qui n'avait pas touché
avant l'écriture lui a permis de faire
ça quelques jours après il devait faire
ce qu'on appelle dans le langage
judiciaire une confrontation devait
aller chez le juge pour la confrontation
avec la victime
est ce qu'il avait écrit l'avait préparé
à faire sa confrontation savez
quand je sors de ces moments là ce n'est
jamais très simple je les quitte en leur
disant si tout va bien jusqu'à la
semaine d'après et parfois il y en a qui
sont entre temps mais j'ai compris que
lutter contre la criminalité contre la
délinquance c'est une mission très
difficile mais c'est une mission où tous
les maillons de la chaîne ont leur
importance
maillon judiciaires policiers familial
éducatif associatif on pouvoir
coordonner mon action j'ai monté une
association qui s'appelle faire une
différence faire une différence son but
c'est de promotionner l'éducation le
vivre ensemble à travers les outils dont
je viens de vous parler est un autre
outil que j'espère développer c'est le
voyage permettre à certains jeunes de
chez nous de sortir pendant un moment de
leur milieu et d'aller ailleurs
les voyages forment la jeunesse ils ont
transformé je vous mentirais si je vous
disais que je fais tout ça parce que je
suis un homme bon un homme qui a un
coeur grand comme ça je vous mentirais
non j'ai l'amour mais jean c'est vrai
pour mon pays quand je dis mon pays je
suis toujours dans une dualité
quand je dis mon pays c'est la
martinique et la guadeloupe g delémont
pour mes gens pour mon pays mais je suis
un homme et j'ai mes limites
j'ai mon égoïsme qui me colle toujours à
la peau mais je le fais parce que je
suis un chrétien protestant et ma foi
chrétienne
les enseignements de celui qui guide ma
vie christ me recommande de faire
attention et de prendre soin du plus
petit de mes frères le plus petit mes
frères dans le langage biblique ça veut
dire celui qui a le moins de ressources
pour affronter les défis de la vie donc
c'est aussi une motivation ça même
motivation qui a poussé l'un de mes
héros a regardé les problèmes de son
pays en face et ce héros là c'est martin
luther king il y à un rappeur j'aime
beaucoup
tu admires apéro préférez vous croirez
peut-être pas mais il est musulman
non il vit il n'est pas très loin dans
le classement
oui kerry est pas très loin dans le
classement mais c'est en fait
ali il s'appelle alice et une moitié
d'un groupe qui n'existe plus et une
moitié d'un groupe qu'il formait avec
booba que vous connaissez et ce groupe
s'appelait lunatique et ali il a
continué sa carrière musicale
hélène chose qui dit je suis d'accord
avec lui il dit le dialogue c'est le
respect de tout un chacun est ma grande
idée on au petit il sait que nous devons
partir des domaines qui influence qui
intéresse qui impacte notre jeunesse de
plein fouet pour pouvoir transmettre des
valeurs éducatives transmettre de
l'éducation transmettre des
connaissances des comportements et pas
le contraire pas partir de notre système
allons leur demander de rentrer dedans
on peut faire du moins on veut un
équilibre entre les lieux le système qui
est en place mais aussi aller vers ceux
qui le tourbillon dans lequel ils sont
aujourd'hui et j'ai vraiment faim j'ai
confiance dans le fait que ça va porter
du fruit
si vous voulez bien j'aimerais bien
partager un texte de rap avec vous ça
vous dit
le texte appelle au pays des misères à
sortir sur mon prochain album est un
groupe de rap j'aime beaucoup qui
s'appelle dead prez sont des gens qui
sont un peu comme moi sont des
activistes et militants mais aussi des
rappeurs alors leur faim dit le refrain
dit conscient comme des de presse jamais
aux extrêmes au mic check c'est sans
faire d'excès der geer au pays des mes
césaire notre poésie illumine la réalité
améliore conçu comme dead prez jamais
aussi extrêmes au moins que j'excelle
sans faire d'excès m j-ch au pays des
mes césaire de poésie illumine la
réalité améliore encore les mots sont
des armes études si au fond rien ma
poésie résiste comme celle de guy
tirolien à ceux qui veulent voir mon
peuple et genou à terre jaune noir si
mes frères comme andré aliker pas besoin
de magnum on a les armes miraculeuses
fatigue et de danser dans le car n'a pas
les autres noms bétonnage de nos terres
agricoles parce qu'elles peuvent qui
produit rien c'est un peuple sans fierté
provisions d'apport pour couvrir nos
besoins et les produits venus d'ailleurs
cher on les taxe ils veulent re place
chez nous pour lui par des sachets nos
enfants sont visés en premier faut vous
le sachiez
dans leurs jouets leurs loisirs et leurs
goûters ils nourrissent une mentalité de
clients il ne veut pas le jeune personne
indépendante mais son sont des petits
cailloux dans leurs souliers your conçus
comme des braises jamais aux extrêmes au
match excellent sans faire d'excès
requiert au pays des mes césaire poésie
illumine la réalité à mejia et je ne
suis pas un homme noir colère j'utilise
ma détermination pour ma nation et
j'utilise ma musique ou créer une
émanation
on montre qu'un nez le reste est intègre
et qu'on n'est pas des jeunes bandits du
bonnet au champagne
malcom avait raison l'éducation c'est la
clé et non la liberté n'est toujours pas
gratuite elle un coup si tu veux vivre
librement penser librement et agir
librement ya pas de miracle les livres
savent très bien si et les barreaux mais
n'entend pas arrêter car ces réponses et
les tiens j'écris plus de punch magic et
les punchs complet au mic
je suis généreux comme tony parker quand
je le tiens je donne toujours des rimes
des six
vior conçus comme des presses jamais osé
extrait au moins que j'ai accès sont
faits avec celles qui ont aimé césaire
notre poésie illumine la réalité
améliore merci
ah si